[Music]
please everybody let's go nuts right now
for the hilarious Byron Bowers
[Applause]
feels good on my face not needed man
I don't be honest cuz it's been weird
for me lately you know I recently got
racially profiled in the art museum
that's weird ain't it think I follow it
around when I was looking at art but I
actually thought I was gonna steal a
painting thought about it it's not my
demographic what I'm gonna set up a
table outside and just try to hustle
some people over a player come here
check this out I got something for your
hands look you like deals look man I got
incense
I got hip-hop CDs oh there's 17th
century painting or three- fat white
women and the woods man no pee-wee
Herman can paint now it's Paul Rubens
this is peter paul rubens player from
the 17th century the Baroque period look
if you notice the bowl comes and
brushstrokes these pimps use back then
you know what screw it it's the last one
it's the only one I want to be great
I'll be honest with y'all I want to be
great I think that's why we here earth
be great and when I thought about all
reason I want to be great
it's so that my greatness outweighs my
inappropriateness
I could do some mess stuff to be but at
least he finally don't worry about it
cuz thing about this is true most great
people have flaws like we all do but
they provide a service so well that they
flaws when I noticed by Beethoven
Beethoven was an alcoholic could he play
the piano so well nobody noticed they
thought he was sweating from playing
hard now he was drunk that's how great I
want to be Walt Disney great man you
know he was racist but he drew cartoon
characters so well that it was years
that he died before people realized and
these cartoons are in blackface i watch
cartoons now like damn that crow got
some big ass lips darling and is in
water Malika dances as I look at it go
crow GoPro GoPro go crossbar dancing
with the crowd its greatness dr. King
great man had women on the side here's
the bane chicks and take naps we're
doing one of those naps he had a dream
that changed the world I'm spiritual -
I'm spiritual
oh no why no Pete I don't know why I
don't know if you know it's cuz I'm from
the Bible Belt like I'm from the south
or because I'm black and we just
naturally scared of stuff it's true we
got fears black people that we fear God
ghosts and magic you ain't never seen a
black magician before heaven think about
it it's been eight Harry Potter's write
8 as I was a film it's been two brothers
in the whole series have you paid
attention they wouldn't even do a magic
in the movie that's why I think they
were in the heart wars on the athletic
scholarship it was the only reason they
were whispering Quidditch players you
know there was only two brothers that
know how to ride a broom cuz that ain't
cool brother on the broom when I look
weird like a mattress my broom I yell
man I might go to Pete Home Show and
check out some chicks headphones and
Jordans man people you think I must feel
like five hundred dollars on the nippers
mm no go right now to the grocery store
get me a cheap broom the right on I'm
not gonna tell you little dustpan off
they come with it I'm just will say it
some spoiling right out but what a
brother's do start ride brooms like you
know like you see him in the projects
sagging their pants they walk around
they broman walking with a pants at the
same time you see how awkward this looks
the streets will be clean as hell but
his walk got my street sweeper it's like
they just trying to pick up a day ain't
Kisha hurry up we're running late leave
your ass I got one foot on his broom
already
soon as I put that other foot on and say
that magic word which would be like a
rapper's name like a flame right here
you know I look tough like the Leanback
if I want to I can hold my sax grab
myself maybe put a little Astro right
here just in case I've smoked some weed
so I'm gonna be up in the clouds while
I'm up in the clouds just chillin
without a care in the world oh it's the
mops
[Applause]
Oh
[Music]